goodbye Ironman hello ironheart
according to a new report by we got this
covered Marvel Studios may have decided
which hero will assume the Ironman
mantle following Tony Stark's death and
Avengers endgame the outlet cites an
unnamed source that claims the bigwigs
at Marvel and Disney are planning to
have RiRi Williams also known as Iron
Heart become the new Iron Man she is
said to be scheduled to debut in the MCU
in either a phase four or a phase five
film and will quote have Tony's suit to
help her the ultimate plan for Iron
Heart / we got this covered
info is to have the hero fight alongside
the New Avengers led by brie Larson's
Captain Marvel for those who haven't
heard of Iron Heart here's a brief
rundown on the character she's an
introverted teenager with genius-level
intellect who was accepted to MIT at age
12 her smarts caused her to retreat into
herself but when she reverse engineered
the Iron Man armor model 41 suit to
create her own version of the armor
something sparked inside her she wound
up stepping into the suit and committing
a few acts of rogue vigilantism before
Tony Stark noticed her and endorsed her
wish to become a superhero ultimately
when Tony slips into a coma after
battling Captain Marvel its RiRi who
carries on his legacy as Iron Heart we
got this coverage report notes that
several characters will attempt to rise
as the new Iron Man these contenders
include Don Cheadle's war machine a
close friend of Tony's and Tom Hollands
spider-man who saw Tony as a father
figure and trained under him to become
an Avenger during spider-man homecoming
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you no we're not there yet
apparently both Warmachine and Spidey
soon realized that the gig just isn't
for them and Iron Heart will go on to
assume the mantle but really how
plausible is the notion that Iron Heart
will be the new Iron Man in the MCU
well it certainly helps that this exact
thing has happened in Marvel Comics in
August of 2016
wired exclusively confirmed that riri
Williams would formally take the Iron
Man torch from Tony Stark during the
events of the new invincible Iron Man
number 1 on the other hand although we
got this coverage does cite a source
it's not a named source any
reading this report and choosing to
believe it or brush it off is doing so
based solely on the word of an anonymous
source now this isn't to say that we got
this covered
aren't reputable quite the opposite
actually and the outlet has hit the head
on numerous nails in the past such as
accurately reporting the Avengers
endgame leaked that revealed that
Chitauri would be in the movie and
reporting the news that Robert Pattinson
was in talks to become the new Batman
months before variety confirmed the
scoop we got this covered really could
be dishing the truth here but without
any corroboration on that source it's
just impossible to know for sure
[Music]
everything considered this could be a
legitimate leak or just a bunch of
hogwash
it would be seriously cool to see a new
hero take over for Tony Stark much like
Anthony Mackey's Falcon is all set up to
become the new Captain America in Steve
Rogers stead and it makes a lot of sense
for Iron Heart to be that person
considering what went down in the comics
and yes fans will certainly have to take
this report with a grain of salt but
regardless of whether RiRi Williams will
be appearing on the silver screen
anytime soon you can probably rest
assured that Kevin Feige and Marvel know
what they're doing and that Tony Stark's
legacy is in good hands check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]